I'm Steve lemme this is kevin heffernan
from tacoma FD premiering on truTV March
28th and we are about to answer the
internet if you were stuck in a food and
had to eat your way out of it what would
it be French onion soup I'm in a bit I'm
in a very French onion soup kind of mood
these days winter it's winter in LA I
had a great one the other day at TGI
Fridays with like a nice like a real
piece of like toast up top and cheese
all I'm talking I think you could fight
your way out of that cheese and it was
uh it was all salty and the thing is
like with the salty thing you'd be
drowning and it'd be like a tougher
climb out of that ice yeah but you'd
have to eat through the hole you'd have
to eat through it and what a way to
rescue yourself how about you okay I
probably talked myself into like a pink
steak okay
I just know my way up now here's the
thing if you're stuck in the middle of a
steak you're cooking especially if you
if you're Ruth's Chris plug another good
place yeah that that steak stays hot and
cooks all the way through the meal
there's a time yeah you gotta go fast
would you rather [ __ ] yourself every
time you have an orgasm or get a random
boner every time you talk to a dude
I would rather [ __ ] myself every time I
had an orgasm I already do yeah but
that's a double orgasm cuz taking a [ __ ]
is fantastic it's orgasmic yeah right
you just be like I mean that's the
ultimate pleasure orgasm is [ __ ] at the
same time right down to this is a super
easy question yeah yeah that's what's
stupid about the question is how easy it
is you have to have a devil's threesome
with one male actor who would it be
Kevin Klein
kevin kline best one of the best actors
of all time a real he influence on my
career and i tell him so while we were
you know is it is the devil's threesome
like a kind of threesome
it is a devil's okay okay I didn't know
I didn't okay okay kevin kline I said
Kevin Kline yeah I'm definitely gonna
thor ragnarok you do right that's
Emsworth yeah but first of all if you're
doing a devil's threesome with thor
ragnarok it's not a devil's threesome
anymore it's you as you watching
Hemsworth have sex with that girl I can
do that too yeah by the way how quickly
if you're in the devil's threesome with
a girl and thor ragnarok yeah and or
Chris Hemsworth who however you want to
address him sure how long do you think
it lasts before the girl just high five
to you and pushes you out of it I think
I know when you get to the bed right
yeah okay you get to have sex with the
girl of your dreams but they hold a
press conference after rating your
sexual performance do you do it yes yes
yeah cuz the rating is gonna be [ __ ]
phenomenal but even if it's not who
gives a [ __ ] I've gotten bad reviews
before sure thank you happy yeah no yeah
movies very bad review yeah that's just
wise that was wise that was wise all
right your mom and your girlfriend
switch bodies only way to get them back
to normal is to bang one of them oh
that's really about sex with your girl
with your mom yeah you have to go with
the with the girl's body and the moms
brain you got to go to buy what are you
talking about you're gonna [ __ ] your
mom's body we're gonna [ __ ] your mom's
body with 73 years old dude you are a
[ __ ] Mets fan
your mom like she's gonna be like
thinking about you [ __ ] her that's
great you're gonna [ __ ] your mom's body
every time you talk to your mom's like
my mother time I [ __ ] you my mom is 73
years old
you're [ __ ] in the head you want your
mom knowing you're the only one in here
who would [ __ ] your mom's body are you
nuts
she might be proud of you that's my boy
like it's not it's not about her it's
about you know that yeah I'm never
coming to barstool sports again [ __ ]
up